I hate this like literally this is like
I'm doing something I hate like oh yeah
hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk and we're
doing a little one-off video that I like
to do once in a while you know D rocks
like hey you get all this stuff why
don't we do like an unboxing thing and I
was like it's a little humblebrag it's a
little weird but then I was like wait a
minute this is a great way to reward
people with an extra little oomph that
are sending stuff right so I figured you
know I found my angle to make me justify
making this so I'm excited I'm really
bad at pronouncing names so this could
get awkward but maybe we should start so
all right I'm over here now do you rock
let's go to the first one this is Beth
bulu all right I get this is it this is
super fun let's see what this is this is
what you want right yes all right it's
Beth's book the introvert entrepreneur
makes sense
I'm the extrovert entrepreneur by the
way since this was the first thing on
the first video please don't send I have
a feeling I'm about to get 8000 books
sent I think we're gonna be very careful
about people hacking the book game I
actually want stuff that I like like
Nikes and like Jets jerseys and like
wear toys from the 80s very rip Oh WWF
wrestlers the rubber wrestlers from the
80s I want those bad so I can put them
on the table Thundercats
those kind of things all right let's go
here I can't watch this here we go
another book yep he's the success for
kids oh this is Caleb who's on the show
Caleb let's give him a little click that
he was on the show very nice good you
got that all right all right I'm really
excited about this who who sent this
thanks very love this this I will use
jets corkscrew and stopper thank you
this owl is always in Mike in my
Instagram feed and I do love these
Simone gets dibs
Alex DeSimone gets dibs he's excited
this I will definitely wear there will
be an Instagram photo of me wearing this
for sure and then some t-shirts all
right oh my god Weiss is great
sure yeah Zhen Wallops alright oh did I
whip something coffee here nice little
note hi happy birthday happy birthday
it's a little one it's a little bit
heavy I like that I'm not super into
unboxing actually I'm actually really
not liking this yeah oh I don't think
we're doing this again I think I need to
sign this this is good it's a little
humblebrag this is me on ink I think
that the sign this one this is a sign to
Randy the Macho Man Savage picture now
this looks like some legal papers a
story how what is this like it's a deck
it thanks so much wrong very nice
awesome all right now this gets to get
some people excited there's some beers
and such who want some black rhino
that's awesome who is that you know
thanks dudes
appreciate a bunch of beers India drink
that you saw before the show I hate this
we're definitely never doing this again
yeah I like literally this is like I'm
doing something I hate I don't even do
this at like oh yeah now I'm into it
things have turned in the right
direction now this is interesting
yes thank you so so much Robert Rove
very nice wuzzle that's that's what I'm
talking about this is a nice condition
yeah I guess so you know bunch of
sneakers and jet stuff starts coming up
oh this feels like more Wuzzles I'm
excited this is all legit this is a real
haul yes look out wuzzle City USA baby
the whole wuzzle crew this is awesome
so pumped thank you so much hainan thank
you so much it's a lot of Wuzzles oh
yeah a wuzzle in package whoo and a
wristband yes thank you so much
Oh baby yes here we go from Paul Barrett
was those on tape I appreciate it isn't
a I'm into it some weird way welcome to
me unbox Gary Misha wine
I'm here Valley Pennsylvania baby some
PA wine thank you so much thank you so
much Heath really appreciate it was the
picture that I really liked from
Catherine on Instagram yeah we're gonna
hang that somewhere thanks for sending
stuff guys
have a great day